what is causality and what is the
difference between causality and
correlation causality is the
relationship between a cause and an
effect in a causal relationship we have
a cause and a resultant effect an
example coffee contains caffeine a
stimulating substance when you drink
coffee the caffeine enters the body
affects the central nervous system and
leads to increased alertedness drinking
coffee is the cause of the feeling of
alertedness that comes afterwards
without drinking coffee the effect I.E
the feeling of alertedness would not
occur but causality is not always so
easy to determine clear requirements
must be met in order to speak of a
causal relationship but more about that
later